take you live right now to the
Lithuanian Capital where NATO Secretary
General Jen stoltzberg is speaking let's
listen
it's like fuel the mining equipment and
medical supplies second a new NATO
Ukraine Council a forum for crisis
consultations and decision making
where we'll meet us equals
and I look forward to having the
inaugural meeting of the council
tomorrow with president zelenski
third we reaffirmed that Ukraine will
become a member of NATO
and agreed to remove the requirement for
a membership action plan
this would change Ukraine's membership
path
from a two-step process to a one-step
process
we also made clear that we will issue an
invitation for Ukraine to join NATO when
Allah and conditions are met
this is a strong package for Ukraine and
a clear path towards its membership in
NATO
allies have also proved the most
comprehensive defense plans since the
end of the Cold War
these are designed to counter the two
main threats we Face Russia and
terrorism
under our new plans NATO aims to have
300 000 troops at high redness including
substantial air and Naval power
robust deterrence and defense requires a
robust industrial base
so leaders endorse the new defense
production action plan this will
accelerate joint procurement boost
interoperability and generate investment
and production capacity
to do all this
we need to invest more in defense
our latest estimate show that defense
expenditure by European allies and
Canada will increase by 8.3 percent
in 2023
this is the biggest increase in decades
since 2014 they will have been invested
an extra
450 billion US dollars in defense
11 allies now reach or exceed the two
percent Benchmark and we expect this
number will rise substantially next year
today allies made an enduring commitment
to invest at least two percent of gross
domestic product annually in defense and
to do more urgently to meet their
commitments
Natalie this also adjusts China
China is not our adversary and we should
continue to engage
but beijing's increasing certainness
affects our security
China is increasingly challenging
challenging the rules based in National
order
refusing to condemn Russia's war against
Ukraine
Taiwan and carrying out substantial
military buildup
China's nuclear modernization is
unprecedented in speed and scale and
being carried out with no transparency
Allah has agreed to continue working
together to protect against China's
coercive Behavior
and tomorrow we will meet the leaders of
Australia Japan New Zealand and South
Korea as well as the European Union
because we are stronger and safer when
we stand together
and with that I'm ready to take a few
questions
not with Washington posts
there in the middle yeah
[Music]
hi thanks for taking my question Michael
Birnbaum from The Washington Post
um president zielinski of course issued
a tweet in the middle of your talks uh
that criticized the language that you've
just agreed to uh on Ukraine's path
toward membership I was wondering
um what your thought was when you saw
what he was saying about what NATO was
agreeing to and what your message would
be for ukrainians who are disappointed
by this language thanks a lot
well the allies allies have agreed today
is a strong United and positive message
to Ukraine about enduring
support but also a positive message or
message on the path forward for
membership and this includes this
package of practical support to enable
full interoperability between Ukrainian
armed forces and NATO forces the
establishment of the NATO Ukraine
Council and then the decision to remove
the requirement for a membership action
plan which actually means that instead
of two steps to become a member they
will allow me one step and um and uh we
also May declare that the invitation
will be issued when conditions are met
um
then I would like to add that on top of
that of course allies are also uh
providing substantial Military Support
uh because the most urgent task now is
to ensure that Ukraine prevails Because
unless Ukraine prevails there is no
membership issue to be discussed at all
and therefore welcome the military
support of the Allies have provided now
for months actually starting back in
2014 and then since the full-fledged
invasion in February last year
substantially stepping up their support
and just uh over uh the last few days
allies have made substantial new
announcements France have announced has
announced that they will deliver a
long-range cruise missiles Germany just
announced a new package with air defense
and armored vehicles and the U.S made
yet another big announcement of more
military support and many other allies
have made different types of support
including the establishment or coalition
to provide training enforcement F-16
fighter jets so put together this is a
strong message
which sends a positive and United a
message to uh to Kiev
we'll go to the Ukrainian news agency in
the third row yeah
national news agency of Ukraine here
thank you foreign question just follow
up my colleague can we expect today a
final communique on Ukraine and we can
expect it tomorrow and could you please
specify what kind of conditions Ukraine
still need to fulfill to initiate the
accession procedure and to get an
invitation thank you
we have agreed to communica and we also
agreed the package for Ukraine that was
agreed by the leaders and I referred the
main
elements now the Practical support their
political ties with the NATO Ukraine
Council full interoperability the
removal of the membership action plan
and then of course also all the
different things that allies are
providing by laterally including with
the new announcements we have heard
today and the the last few days
um I have
uh been in close contact and regular
contact and NATO allies have also been
in regular contacts with uh with
Ukrainian officials I've discussed this
also with uh with president zelenski and
I look forward to uh to meet him tonight
uh and then also to have the inaugural
meeting of the NATO uh Ukraine Council
tomorrow
where I will set out the package of the
three elements
bringing a Ukraine closer to Nato and
this is a a strong package
okay
right over there
Andrew maybe you can just ask your
question
um Andrew Gray from Reuters executive
General to come back to president
zorenski's remarks he said it would be
absurd if the time frame is not set
neither for invitation nor for Ukraine's
membership how would you respond to that
specific point and why have allies not
set out a time frame today
what we have agreed is a very
substantive package with many different
elements that helps to move Ukraine
closer to Nato help them to move
towards NATO membership and this is
partly a very practical support on for
instance interoperability and reforms
defense sector reforms and
interoperability are among the
conditions which are important for a
membership so that's a practical way of
moving them and moving Ukraine closer to
to Nato
then we also send a strong political
message with the language on a
membership including the language which
is now in the communique on invitation
so there's never been a stronger message
from NATO at any time both when it comes
to the political message on the path
forward for membership and the concrete
support from NATO allies Military
Support but also the practical support
on how to ensure full interoperability
so uh so uh and if you look at other
membership processes they're not been a
time
lines for those processes they are
conditions based has always been
okay we'll go to the gentleman here in
the second round
from Finland Mr Secretary General the
Baltic Sea becomes NATO's Inland Sea
NATO puts 300 000 new troops on high
Readiness
what does all this mean for Frontline
countries like Finland Estonia Latvia
Lithuania and Poland and what is NATO's
message to Mr Putin and Russia how
historic is this moment thank you
it is historic that both Finland and
Sweden will become members of a NATO
finan is only only their full member and
uh with the agreement uh that uh
president adirond and the Prime Minister
John and I were able to make a last
night
Sweden has also become a full member of
the alliance this is historic it's
important for the whole Alliance it's
important for Finland it's important for
for Sweden but it is uh also in
particular important for the the Baltic
region because when you look at the map
you realize that for instance
the the the POS the ability to reinforce
the Baltic region is very much improved
by the fact that we now have thin and
and soon also Sweden as as full members
and that will be reflected in our
defense plans and our exercises in our
kpt targets and everything else we do
asked in the lines so it makes the whole
Alliance stronger and it makes
especially the Baltic region a safer it
sends the message that NATO's store is
open it sends the message that is for
NATO allies to decide
on enlargement is not from Moscow to
deny Sovereign Nation Nations the
certain right to choose their own path
and this is again something we have
demonstrated not only in words but also
in Deeds by now allowing to new members
and sending a message to Ukraine which
is stronger than any message NATO has
ever sent before on membership for
Ukraine
um
we have the gentleman over there in the
third row
over there
uh European proper Ukraine Secretary
General I would ask you to clarify a bit
on conditions I understand that you
cannot list all of them it's probably
not clear but maybe you see how these
conditions would be defined agreed
because I I'm afraid that uh it would be
read that NATO Has Lifted membership
action plan but have uh in the invented
another membership action plan with
another name which is condition so it's
like making a bit of a fake achievement
thank you
no what we say in the communique is that
Ukraine has moved beyond the requirement
for a membership action plan just
because Ukraine has come much closer to
Nato I was actually attending the NATO
uh Summit in Bucharest in 2008 as a
Norwegian prime minister and I remember
very well the discussion there and of
course the discussion now is totally
different for many reasons and not least
because Ukraine is under full-fledged
attack by by Russia but also because
Ukraine has come so much closer to these
Alliance over all these years because
especially since 2014 when NATO allies
started to train and equip Ukrainian
Armed Forces but even more so after 20
after February last year
Ukraine has demonstrated
capabilities
skills and has been more and more
integrated with with NATO this is also a
consequence of the equipment which NATO
allies are delivered ring because for
instance when we deliver more than
battle tanks or Advanced Air Defense
systems a consequence of that is also
more interoperability more NATO
standards doctrines and a gradual
movement from the Soviet era doctrines
standards and equipment to Nato just by
the fact that so much equipment is now
delivered and of course when we start
training with the
trainer Pilots for f-16s it will even
more add to this important
interoperability which has always been a
requirement for NATO membership so this
is this is this is moving Ukraine closer
to uh to to Nate and to Nato membership
and also reflecting the fact that that
NATO has come much closer
well we have we have conditions partly
in the in in the in article 10 of the
transatlantic tree to the Washington
treaty and then of course at the end of
the day it has to be allies that assess
where their conditions are fully met or
not and that's exactly what Allison had
to agree and therefore also refer to
both the conditions but also the need
for all allies to read that's the way we
make decisions NATO
where did you go I need to go here
um thank you Secretary General just to
follow up on this important topic I have
in front of me the text from uh 2008
from Bucharest which we've all been
reading and rereading over the past
weeks uh Anita welcomes ukraines and
Georgia's your Atlantic aspirations
membership in NATO we agreed today that
these countries will become members of
NATO so if if you were explaining just
to um you know the average citizen in in
the alliance and in Ukraine people who
are really Keen to understand what was
decided today how would you explain the
difference between the tax that was
agreed in Bucharest in 2008 and the
specific language that was agreed today
there are several differences one
important difference is that I think the
next sentence or at least a bit the
further down we say that the next step
is membership action plan and that's
exactly what we removed today and at
every Summit 2008 we have said uh
Ukraine will become a member and the
next step is membership action plan now
we remove that so that's actually
turning this process which has always
been two steps into one step that
actually moves Ukraine closer to
membership and it's a significant
difference from the 2008 language which
has been reiterated at every Summit
since 2008. and it has been also a
process in NATO to make that decision
because it was not a was a
straightforward decision to to make I'm
glad that allies agreed and it was the
main element in my package I launched in
Oslo in May at the informal meeting then
it was a questions there were questions
asked whether that was to move too fast
and therefore I'm glad that since May
since it started this discussion of
removing a map requirement all allies
today have agreed to remove a map
requirement so that's a difference
number one difference number two is is
that we actually now have a program for
how to help and support Ukraine move
closer to Nato and that is the the
interoperability the multi-air program
but also the the strengthening our
political ties and also reference to
that the foreign
assess progress so this together with
the fact that the the substantial
delivery of of equipment and training
just by itself moves Ukraine also to
membership is a big big difference there
is one more difference and that is that
in 2008 Ukraine was quite far from NATO
what has happened since 2008 has has
already moved them much closer
Swedish radio
a strong and United message to Ukraine
on support and on its membership the
words there of Yen saltenberg as he was
addressing this NATO Summit underscoring
what exactly they've agreed when it
comes to Ukraine's application for
membership that's been a a hot issue
there at the summit clearly evident
demonstrated by the questions that are
coming up in that press conference on
our diplomatic editor James Bays joins
us now from Vilnius and James as I said
it's quite clear here that the issue of
Ukraine's membership has been a very big
issue in this conference it's also clear
that there is not going to be a
timetable for membership right is that
the most important Takeaway on the
Ukraine on the Ukraine issue
yeah Ukraine Ukraine and president
zielinski are not going to be happy with
what they're hearing here president
zenski has already made that clear on
his flight over when he heard and I've
heard so many different versions of this
language when he heard the final version
that was being discussed he tweeted uh
he said it was unprecedented and
absurd not to set a time frame for
invitation to membership and for actual
membership and that is what uh Secretary
General stoltenberg has just done in
that news conference he's announced what
the 31 allies have decided ambassadors
couldn't reach an agreement on the words
in the end it had to go to the to the
leaders sitting around the table in a
closed session to come up with the words
uh saying that Ukraine will become a
NATO member but it says we will issue
the invitation when allies agree and
conditions permit so it's very vague and
you heard in one of those questions
there how is this different from 2008
all those years ago the Bucharest Summit
when they said that NATO will be that
Ukraine will become a NATO a member and
the Secretary General there tried to
answer it clearly the circumstances are
very different but in terms of what
Ukraine has to do how is it different
well they've dropped this thing you had
it mentioned there they call it the map
the membership application plan uh that
is a series of Hoops targets that each
country has to meet in order to reach
NATO's standard economically politically
and militarily they say well Ukraine's
at War right now and Ukraine is working
so closely with the NATO allies they
don't need to have that map process in
that place but what's not clear and I
think this is the big question for
ukrainians as he keeps talking about a
conditions-based process what are the
conditions what are the conditions that
Ukraine must meet and that is not being
laid out by NATO allies and that I think
is what is frustrating ukrainians they
want to be members of NATO as soon as
possible they've been waiting since 2009
8 and president zielinski I think from
his tweets earlier on and his comments
in the last month or so is not going to
be happy with what he's been offered
here he is now in Vilnius and he joins
those 31 NATO allies for dinner tonight
and then for a meeting tomorrow of
something called uh the Ukraine NATO
Council used to be called the name
Ukraine NATO commission it's an upgrade
not just a name change now Ukraine can
convene meetings and one thing
significant about that years ago at the
end of the Cold War there was actually a
Russia Ukraine a Russia NATO Council
where NATO used to sit with Russia and
discuss issues well Russia no longer is
there that's completely Mori bound and a
similar body now exists for Ukraine but
that was agreed well before the summit
so I still don't think this is going to
appease uh president zielinski so
perhaps some tough talk over dinner
James I'm so glad you mentioned the
issue of conditions because it was clear
during that press conference the yen
altenberg was repeatedly asked by
several reporters to outline what are
the conditions that Ukraine has got to
meet and I think it's fair to say there
wasn't really a clear answer on that the
clearest we got was referring one
journalist to article 10 of the the NATO
founding document which does in itself
just says if any country can meet the
conditions it can apply to join is that
a reflection of really a lack of
consensus within NATO about what the
conditions should be that's why in
sultanburg couldn't really explain it
oh absolutely some of the nations in
northern Europe would like to see this
speeded up very fast some would even
like I think if they they probably
wouldn't say it publicly but privately
would like a a a membership of Ukraine
very very fast indeed
um but others and most publicly are
saying it needs to be after the war ends
some say immediately after the war ends
what uh some NATO nations are worried
about is you get an end of a war
situation some sort of ceasefire where
Russia still occupies part of Ukraine so
there's still even just even if there's
a ceasefire there's still an active
conflict ongoing and that if Ukraine
became a NATO Ally Then under Article 5
which if one um Allied nation is
attacked then all the others have to
have to join in and and offer the
necessary assistance it's called the
all-for-one article in NATO uh then
effectively if there was further
fighting and then NATO would be dragged
into a into a full-scale war with Russia
that's the worry of sums a difference of
opinions they have not been able to
bridge the gap I think here so a
somewhat fudge in the words and that
fudge is not going to please president
zielinski who will be here tomorrow in
fact we're going to see him giving a
press conference after he's had his
meeting with NATO with Mr stoltenberg
tomorrow let's see if those differences
are on display then all right thanks so
much our diplomatic editor James Bay is
there
Ukraine's President Vladimir zielinski
is that that NATO Summit in Lithuania
now he's pressing for his country to
have membership of the defense Alliance
as James Bays was explaining there so
let's go live now to the Ukrainian
capital and speak to our correspondent
Rob McBride so Rob does it sound like
listening to that
there's going to be a lot of
disappointment right now in Kiev
I think people were expecting uh this
kind of message from stoltenberg to
begin with he'd already a telegraphed
that he was going to give strong words
of support for Ukraine's position
talking about strong United positive but
everything falling short of this actual
time scale for just when a Ukraine would
become a full NATO member I think there
is an acceptance here in Ukraine that
there is some division between NATO
members that some NATO members feel that
if you do give almost an automatic
guarantee of membership of NATO as soon
as the fighting ends that that in some
way may encourage Russia to con to
escalate this conflict to drag out this
conflict but then as many people here in
Ukraine would say they're shown no sign
over the past what nearly a year and a
half of wanting to do any kind of
de-escalation and as zielinski has done
before now in calling for uh for main
battle tanks and then F-16 seen Jets and
eventually getting these concessions
from NATO members and the Western allies
they really would have liked to get some
sort of guarantee of a of a concrete
road map to Nato membership but as we
saw there uh the net the Yen stoltenberg
falling short of that but talking about
interoperability of uh of of of
Ukrainian forces with NATO so Paving the
way for NATO membership at some point so
giving some consolations and also
reminding the ukrainians which they will
be welcoming here about the extra Aid
packages uh with mentioning the
long-range missiles from France the 700
million euros military aid package from
Germany all he says are helping Ukraine
Prevail because he makes the point which
is a fair point to make but unless
Ukraine does prevail does win on the
battlefield then all this talk of NATO
membership is a purely academic but
again when zielinski who is now in
Vilnius has been talking about uh saying
this is absurd that they don't have this
time scale uh stoltenberg really
avoiding that and just going back to his
position that uh a fairly woolly
position that that all of the members
have to agree at some point on the
conditions without that setting out what
those conditions are before that all
important invitation will be issued all
right thanks so much Rob McBride there
now as we mentioned turkey has demanded
concessions to back Sweden's membership
of NATO it wants Stockholm to crack down
on groups it considers National Security
threats including the pkk and ypg it
wants F-16 fighter jets from the US and
the Turkish government also wanted an
arms embargo lifted which Sweden
immediately complied with
Sweden has committed to supporting
turkia's bid to revive the process of
joining the European Union let's go live
to Dominic Kane he joins us from Berlin
and Dominic I'm sure you remember
Germany is one of those countries I
think in 2017 where the chancellor at
times said it wanted to end turkey's
membership talks how is this effort now
to try and reinvigorate them going down
where you are
the thing to remember in so far as
turkey turkey and the EU is concerned is
that it has been decades this idea of
accession talks about a Turkish entry
into the EU have been going on since
1987 back then it was the European
economic Community now it's the EU and
yet the talks well they have seemed to
go on and then go off and then come back
on again for as I say decades it is also
accurate to say that the former
chancellor of Germany Angela Merkel in
2017 when she was seeking re-election
said that she wanted to end forever the
idea of accession talks between turkey
and the EU her successor as Chancellor
all have shots has been perhaps slightly
more emollient where this issue is
concerned and spoke to reporters earlier
today
at the last European Council we decided
how we want to further develop the
relationship between turkey and the
European Union and we also asked the
European commission to submit proposals
and reports so that we can do so I will
also talk to president erdogan here
turkey is an important partner for us
and this will be expressed in the future
relations
other EU heads of government heads of
states have been more unequivocal
certainly Xavier better in the prime
minister of Luxembourg saying pretty
clearly that the EU has had problems in
its relations with Tokyo going back some
considerable time now they want to try
and concentrate on cooperation not on
those problems but it's also worth
making one point very clear just as
there are conditions for a country to
accede to Nato so there are conditions
that for a country to accede to the EU a
market economy humanitarian issues the
commitment to democracy and the rule of
law and there are leaders of European
countries inside the EU who do have real
concerns about the possibility of Ankara
becoming the latest EU capital city
all right we'll leave it there thanks so
much Dominic Kane
and Sergey lagolinski is a member of the
European Parliament and chair of the EU
turkia delegation joins us live from
strasbour good to have you with us so
has anything changed from what you can
see when it relates to some of the
concerns which the EU has advocated over
the years about turkey's membership
things like the rule of law the powers
of the Turkish presidency human rights
and so on
no
from the perspective of the European
Parliament nothing changed and I am
happy to hear and we definitely welcome
the membership to the upcoming
membership of Sweden and we're happy
that uh turkey has seized its a blockade
uh on that however the path to this
decision uh was quite
uh puzzling to many of us and we were
concerned and we are concerned how much
of uh China has been uh has been broken
on the paths and the most important uh
China the most important
Capital that we have is the trust Mutual
trust with allies NATO allies and this
is something that I think turkey or
turkey and the government have damaged
on the path especially with the last
proposal to link it to the turkey as
membership in the EU which is quite
surprising and quite puzzling would a
change in position or an increase in
support of countries like Sweden if
that's the indication that they would
support now turkey's accession bid to
the EU does that change the Dynamics
uh to be frank and you know I'm one of
those in this Parliament who Advocate uh
um a Turkish future as EU member uh
there are not so many of us here in this
Parliament uh a majority in this
Parliament uh uh wants to stop not just
to freeze but to stop uh the accession
process
I do not agree with that however we have
substantial obstacles on our way to
de-freezing uh this process and I don't
think that there will be any new
Dynamics with just one offset 27
countries uh thinking otherwise we
already have Advocates uh in the ranks
of EU members but even one country or
two countries like Cyprus like Greece
who have substantial security concerns
uh they can block this process already
so
um I am not sure how much of an
advantage on half of Macho was
substantial for progress turkey has been
able to accomplish on that front uh
considering what the outcome that we we
saw these days or if we look at things
from ankara's perspective in 2018 urduan
said the EU is basically wasting anchor
his time he's had concerns he said Turks
were no longer interested on losing
interest in joining the EU should there
be more concern within the EU about
losing the potential partnership with an
important country like turkey
I think we should take this seriously
and wish you do our best to a show that
we are sincerely interested in uh this
in deepening this relationship
um I do think that and I think this is
the direction that will be taken by the
EU we should start uh uh showing more
interest for example in issues like an
updating of uh Customs Union uh with
turkey I think uh there might be new
Dynamics regarding uh Visa
liberalization issue something that the
turkey as government is very interested
in
um however regarding opening chapters uh
and you know the accession process works
with chapters these are kind of like
thematic Fields uh packages in which uh
EU negotiates with the candidate so we
have 16 uh out of 33 open chapters with
turkey and only one has been closed this
is about science and research
um it stopped it came to a Seas out of
two reasons number one is the
backsliding in Turkey regarding uh
democracy uh and rule of law we cannot
seriously consider someone becoming a
member who has a anti-terror legislation
like this who has political prisoners
Etc and the second part is of course the
original uh policies of of turkey also
uh threatening uh members of the
European Union uh like Cyprus and Greece
uh this uh two stumbling blocks and it
will be very very difficult uh to move
on without having worked on that
all right thank you for your thoughts on
that Sergey lagandowski